E aí
[Música]
e há poucos momentos na vida em que
sentimos tamanha fragilidade do que
quando Estamos doentes
É nesse momento nós vamos em busca de
alguém que possa nos ajudar um médico
e o que você leva para esse momento
quantas angústias quantas preocupações e
medos você leva para esse encontro
e como médica eu gostaria de contar um
pouco a minha história de como eu me
apaixonei pela medicina e por poder
ensinar essa arte a tantas e tantas
gerações que cuidam de todos nós
e o meu começo a medicina não foi algo
muito rápido na verdade eu era uma
adolescente apaixonada por astronomia eu
sempre quis ser cientista mas quando
tinha 15 anos de idade uma doença
cardíaca levou minha avó e no mesmo ano
um amigo muito querido de Infância após
semanas e semanas em uma UTI por um
acidente de carro
e naquele momento esses sentimentos me
fizeram pensar será que eles poderiam
ter sobrevivido
Será que Alguém poderia ter feito algo
diferente
e aquilo fez nascer em mim uma esperança
de quem sabe no futuro talvez eu pudesse
fazer a diferença na vida de outros
Oi e esse foi o meu primeiro chamada e
foi ali que eu decidi que seria médica e
dedicarei a minha vida a salvar outras
vidas
e eu tenho que se passou e alguns anos
depois a dentro da faculdade de medicina
em meio a muitos livros professores
brilhantes pesquisas horas e horas de
estudo e noites sem dormir eu me deparei
com um fato
que uns certos momentos a forma de como
eu aprendi a minhas habilidades como
futura médica talvez não fosse a forma
mais humanizada
quer saber exemplo
acredito que a maior parte de vocês
talvez já tenha entrado no avião Imagine
nesse momento que você entra na aeronave
você se senta Você fecha os eu sinto
então você escuta o comandante senhoras
e senhores aqui o comandante da aeronave
Esse é o meu primeiro voo Mas não se
preocupe porque tudo vai dar certo onde
todos os manuais
e imagina né E porque eu conto isso
porque essa história me faz lembrar do
primeiro parto que eu fiz um e eu era
aluna de medicina e me lembro como se
fosse hoje porque afinal de contas todo
aluno de medicina sonha com esse momento
em ver ali o milagre da vida eu estava
lá com meu professor com meus colegas
residentes enfermeiros no centro
obstétrico é um dia à noite era uma
noite na verdade
então eu assistir pela primeira vez fora
dos livros um quarto acontecendo meu
professor realizando o quarto aquele Foi
emocionante logo depois nós somos
chamados para sala ao lado aonde uma
gestante estava ganhando seu primeiro
bebê praticamente já dá-nos
É nesse momento o meu professor me deu
um empurrãozinho e disse vai lá agora
você faz sozinha
e agora eu respirei fundo eu coloquei as
luvas e para mim ter cheguei lá pensando
meu deus eu não posso esquecer não posso
deixar seu bebê cair não cheguei lá na
cabeça parecendo e fui lá respirei fundo
e Tentei lembrar de tudo hein
E o bebê nasceu em um parto é perfeito
não na verdade não foi assim na verdade
aquele Foi um momento muito tenso para
mim porque havia visto tudo aquilo por
Livros apenas uma vez
é na realidade um paramento e coloquei
minhas luvas e cheguei perto da gestante
viu bebê vindo mas havia algo de errado
a coloração do bebê não estava normal
estava mais arroxeado
então eu percebi que o cordão umbilical
estava fazendo uma circular em volta do
pescoço dele e que a cada contração
ficava mais e mais apertado eu olhei
pela sala e Procurei meu professor
professor tem algo de errado e o viúvo
residente do outro lado gritando
circular tira circular e eu pensando eu
não vi nunca lhe tirado o bebê quem te
dá uma circular e nesse momento eu
apavorada e o professor se aproximou com
a serenidade de quem já fez aqui no mil
vezes retirou circulares de cordão e eu
pude a parar o bebê ali na célula
e eu fiquei naquele momento
fantasiado olhando para ele tentando
assimilar tudo aquilo que eu tinha
passado
entreguei o bebê a pediatra e olhei nos
olhos da mãe
é aquele momento eu pensei
será que passou pela cabeça dela quando
ela viu e ouviu tudo aquilo e há outros
momentos Por exemplo quando eu realizava
visitas à beira leito com meus colegas
de faculdade
eu me lembro muito bem que éramos eu e
mais 15 colegas e o professor em torno
de um paciente um senhor de idade com
insuficiência cardíaca Já pensei Vera
com muita dificuldade de respirar e o
professor pedir aqui um a um nós escutar
seguimos o coração daquele paciente para
que pudéssemos reconhecer um moído uma
alteração um sopro cardíaco
e é bem verdade que naquela época não
havia muitas formas de se aprender a
diferente disso mas aquilo me deixou
pensando
aquilo parto e algumas outras
experiências
Será que realmente não houve uma outra
forma de aprender Será que não havia uma
outra forma de se ensinar e que
mantivesse o paciente de forma mais
segura
é aquilo foi o meu segundo chamado
e o tempo se passou novamente e eu
cheguei ao final da faculdade aquele no
momento limpa para mim em poucos meses a
me tornaria médica e poderia atender
meus pacientes
poderia finalmente salvar vidas
mas aquele momento algo aconteceu
e eu me vi do outro lado da moeda
e quando cheguei no meu último semestre
da Doce severamente
e eu comecei a ter sintomas que não eram
muito fácil de distinguir Eu lembro que
eu procurei nos livros e fiz o que todos
aqui fariam eu fui buscar o especialista
e quando eu cheguei na consulta eu levei
a ele todos aqueles meus medos
as minhas angústias e até ideia que eu
pensava que talvez pudesse ser uma
doença de pâncreas
um especialista de muito renomado na
verdade ajude uma forma que eu não
esperava ele me disse que nada daquilo
era realidade que eu não estava sentindo
aquilo que era impossível aquele
diagnóstico
e me mandou para casa
é só que eu não estava errada
eu estava certa eu precisei da ajuda de
amigos e fiquei internada por esse
problema e eu quase morri
elevaram-se Dois longos anos eu já
dentro da residência médica para que eu
pudesse recuperar minha saúde
o adoecer de forma tão grave me fez ver
e perceber a importância da relação
médico-paciente
a importância de você saber o vídeo e
formativa de você ver o paciente como um
todo e principalmente de você entender
as diferentes nuances da forma como a
doença se apresenta em cada um porque o
diagnóstico pode ser mesmo mas o
adoecimento individual é diferente para
cada um
Oi e esse foi meu terceiro chamado e
foram esses três chamados que fizeram
com que eu me tornasse o que moldasse a
médica que eu sou hoje e também por
esses três chamados que fizeram com que
eu escolhi essa minha especialidade que
a medicina de família e comunidade
e também é verdade que foram esses
chamados que me conduzido por um outro
caminho juntamente da Medicina o de
ensinar essa arte a tantas e tantas
gerações ao de ser professora de curso
de medicina
bom então há 11 anos é isso que eu venho
me dedicando e quando eu cheguei na
faculdade eu comecei a ser professora
uma ideia passou pela minha cabeça
como eu poderia ensinarmos estudantes de
uma forma diferente daquela que eu havia
aprendido como eu poderia trazer mais
segurança para os pacientes e fazer com
que eles se tornassem melhores médicos E
para isso Eu me especializei uma técnica
que a chamada simulação Clínica a
simulação Clínica é uma ferramenta é uma
forma de ensinar a medicina em que ela
simula situações do mundo real
e os alunos são imersos em ambientes que
são idênticos a centros cirúrgicos
ambulatórios pronto-socorros
e ali eles têm contato com manequins que
são robôs de última geração são
manequins que consegue mimetizar as
mesas os mesmos sintomas as mesmas
situações que passam um paciente e ali
eles conseguem perder auscultar consegue
prender palpar a fazer procedimentos
Olá tudo isso se baseia não sou nesses
robôs tudo se baseia no ciclo de
desenvolvimento e aprendizado onde nós
colocamos os nossos estudantes diante de
uma vivência diante de uma experiência
que é muito próxima do real após isso
nós podemos discutir com eles e ele
chega a conclusões
elaboram suas próprias possibilidades e
nós podemos discutir diagnósticos e onde
podemos melhorar e depois disso nós
seguimos para a prática aplicação disso
na vida real
e a simulação por mais incrível que ela
seja ela nunca substituirá o contato
humano a humano mas ela prepara o
profissional para quando ele for atender
o seu paciente
se você se lembra daquela história lá do
parto e hoje em dia os alunos têm aula
com simuladores que são muito
realísticos a rompimento de bolsa você
de saída de líquido e o sangue você
consegue aqui mimetizar situações
críticas como Aquela da circular de
cordão ou até um parto por fórceps
e aqui eles podem fazer isso no ambiente
seguro e repetir quantas vezes forem
necessárias para que evitem os erros no
futuro
Hoje em dia a simulação na verdade ela
até evoluiu hoje nós temos simulação por
realidade virtual por realidade
aumentada e temos ajuda a inclusive de
atores que são profissionalizados em
poder simular pacientes com diversas
patologias
é óbvio que esse tipo de tecnologia não
é algo às vezes muito acessível ela
precisa de treino precisa de
investimento e talvez por reconhecer
isso eu e meus alunos resolvemos que nós
poderíamos realizar isso aqui no Brasil
então nos reunimos em um grupo
multidisciplinar
aonde médicos Engenheiros designers
arquitetos trabalham juntos para
desenvolver simuladores nacionais e
poder levar esse tipo de técnica esse
tipo de tecnologia a mais alunos por
exemplo com manequim de ausculta
cardíaca
criado com manequim de loja
e o por exemplo um aparelho para
aprender fazer exame de ouvido em
crianças e adultos
e ali eles podem aprender certo de
Diagnósticos que se não forem feitos o
momento certo podem levar por exemplo
uma criança surdas
Ah e tudo isso feito de forma
multidisciplinar
e já que estamos falando disso porque
não usar a criatividade alegria Nós
criamos jogos
jogos como por exemplo um board game
onde os alunos aprendem exame físico
diagnóstico e raciocínio clínico
Ah e quanto interação médico-paciente e
quanto ao cuidado e humanismo isso
também pode ser trabalhado dentro da
simulação Clínica aqui nós podemos
trabalhar interação dele com paciente
ainda mais a minha disciplina quer ser
miologia a base da Medicina algum de um
ensino a entrevistar um paciente há como
realizar o exame físico acumu pensar no
sinais e sintomas que representa e eu
tenho grande alegria de poder liberar um
laboratório de comunicação aonde o meus
alunos podem trabalhar com atores que
simulam quadros clínicos e aqui eles
aprendem empatia acumu vir com qualidade
a como examinar da forma correta a como
perceber nuances e também criar
habilidades soft Skills e Pontos
importantes no ensino médico como por
exemplo como dar uma notícia de forma
empática
a ensinar medicina para mim é uma grande
alegria em um grande privilégio e uma
grande responsabilidade
pois trabalhamos com aqueles que
cuidaram de todos nós no futuro
e essa história que eu contei para vocês
é para demonstrar que é possível sim nos
transformarmos a forma como ensinamos os
nossos futuros profissionais
e essa história também mostra que
independente dos percalços que você
passa na sua vida você pode transformar
aquilo que você está passando em algo em
prol da melhoria do futuro e de outras
pessoas
Olá tudo isso ele se resume em algo
atender o chamado atender a chamada de
uma medicina mais humana e se você fizer
isso quando você perceber você terá sido
chamado obrigado
E aí